I use freezer-packed mittens and slippers for the first chemo and plan to use them again for the second as well
second round is tomorrow
However, I've been having occasional numbness and tingling in my fingertips. It goes away for the most part
If I get active and intentionally pumped blood into my hands is this a sign of the beginning of neuropathy
um, it certainly can be
neuropathy is going to be um typically neuropathy is going to start with tingling
um and uh and some pain in your hands and tingling and then you're going to get numbness it goes to
numbness um uh so anything can happen even after one round of chemo so the ice can help that so
you see those freezer packs can be helpful if so is this unavoidable at this point can I do
something to stop it I would say continue to do those types of things again you can look at
the neuropathy posts and look at possibly using a rebuilder make sure you're doing die and pro wave
make sure you're supporting liver uh pathways everything that we talk about with liver and detox
and um uh doing coffee animals and such like that are going to be the best help to try to get that
stuck out of your body so it's just the least amount of damage to your peripheral nerves